let's talk about the descendants ever
since this idea was greenlit everyone's
been sending me Ling's and updates about
what an awful idea this is a Disney
Channel movie about famous animated
Disney villains who have rowdy teenage
kids that go to school
everyone's been going on and on about
just how stupid this is and yeah it's
pretty bad is it the worst of these
Disney Channel movies I've seen no are
there definitely times where there's a
lot of effort put in absolutely but it's
still pretty bad i what you even do it
just comes from an awful idea
in a faraway land Belle and the Beast
rule all the fairy tale kingdoms I guess
and they merge them all together but put
all the Disney villains on this island
that's actually a little bigger than the
good Kingdom that's confusing keeping
them separate
but Belle and the Beast son who's gonna
be king soon has a brave new idea that
the offspring of these villains should
be allowed to go to their school treat
it like any other decent human being
these kids include the son of Corolla
Deville the son of Jafar the daughter of
the Evil Queen and the daughter of
Maleficent and if you're excited to see
the live-action version of your favorite
Disney Villains your book should invade
these are treated like the Adam West's
Batman villains if the last route of
dignity was waterboarded out of them
they're barely even recognizable outside
of their clothes in fact if you had them
in completely different clothes you
probably won't even be able to tell
which villains they were man just when I
thought they couldn't do Maleficent
worse than Angelina Jolie we get this
interpretation the mistress of all evil
one of the greatest Disney villains ever
is now a snorting high-pitched squealing
bad joke cracking twit
and the others are not much better but
nevertheless they see an opportunity
when their kids are invited to go to
school among the good people and they
convinced them to steal the ultimate
weapon of power the magic wand from the
fairy godmother who runs the school but
wouldn't you know it the longer they
stay there the more they realize they
might like being good
oh it's so much conflict and maybe
that's the biggest surprise about
descendants is that there is legit
conflict the kids all do a good job
portraying what they're supposed to
portray honestly every actor does I
don't they told Kathy Najimy to play the
Evil Queen as this dignified evil
villain no it's Kathy Najimy you got her
to be funny she as well as all the other
actors are giving exactly what's being
asked for it just so happens what's
being asked for is incredibly stupid
half the time they really try to make
the Disney characters look like the
Disney characters you know that's
Maleficent you know that's the Evil
Queen they have the stained-glass window
from Beauty and the Beast
even the title descendants has the
Disney D in it but it so obviously
doesn't go with what they're trying to
do here there's scenes of the kids
trying sweets for the first time because
they've never had chocolate or good
fruit or anything like that they start
getting teary eyed when they hear how
other parents treat their kids and
compare it to their parents there's a
downright uncomfortable moment when the
mother of Sleeping Beauty totally
disregards the daughter of Maleficent
because she couldn't see her daughter
for 16 years and it's treated with all
seriousness I okay so got to take this
early seriously maybe you should cut
seams like this it will help you find a
thing like my waistline like some magic
these things clearly don't go together
and I have no idea how this was supposed
to work the only possible way I could
see this may be working is if you never
actually see the villains like you see
the kids but the villains are always
kept in shadow and they're legitimately
intimidating and scary and like your
imagination can fill in how threatening
they are but no they have song and dance
numbers right off of a cheesy Broadway
show this is so clearly not the
Maleficent from the original movie but
it's not this other Maleficent you're
trying to create either that's like
really intimidating and destroyed a lot
of lives and everything either she's a
joke she's a punchline but the movie
doesn't always treat it that way the
song and dance numbers are similar at
first they're actually kind of
impressive this is the guy who did the
High School Musical film so yeah it's
choreographed really nice the songs at
first are kind of catchy heck even the
emotional ones are done relatively well
much better than camp rockers
girls anyway I feel legitimate emotion
here but then you immediately take that
point away when you hear their R&B
version of be our guest oh god stop stop
stop like I said it's kind of hard to
blame the director or the actors cuz it
very much feels like they're just
following orders and they're doing it as
best they can but the order is a tone
confused mess and just not a good idea
like at all they talk about prejudice
and the sins of the parents that
shouldn't be passed down to the kids and
yeah that's something for older kids to
get into it's very relevant
he's clearly meant for kindergarteners
and half the time that's how it's
portrayed except one is trying to be
portrayed as this really dramatic
musical oh yes so it is really stupid
but I will give credit it's not as
stupid as a good event
well okay very large chunks are but
there's also a lot of very talented
songwriters choreographers singers
dancers actors it's the right people for
the wrong project it's hard to know who
the audience is supposed to be but
seeing how they made a sequel I guess it
did find an audience and and they liked
it good for them like I said there's
really nothing wrong in it it's just so
stupid if this is the kind of corny
insanity that does it for you I'd be
lying if I said I didn't almost
understand it is fascinating in its
choices but if you're looking for a
movie where all this talent comes
together in a coherent story then you
ain't gonna live happily ever after
you